I will definitely read these messages
together tonight presented with messages
of love from supporters across the world
to feed our keeps parents described this
as the first day of the rest of their
lives their daughter who has severe
brain damage is now settled at the
gasolene II Children's Hospital facing
the world the toll it's taken on her
mother was clear I don't think I could
say any more because I am feeling
emotionally drained I think I was burst
in tears very soon I mean I I'm sure
everyone knows that taffy that was a
very happy bubbly child before February
and in February our life has actually
been turned upside down I mean she was
she wasn't born under well she wasn't
born with the condition she's due to
have a breathing tube inserted the hope
is one day she can go home
[Music]
to feed our suffered ruptured blood
vessels in her brain in February she
hasn't left hospital in eight months
until yesterday when her journey began
from an airport in South London her
British doctors argued that this trip
would cause further physical degradation
they lost their case in court while
arriving here might be good news for one
family the case strikes to the heart of
a deeply controversial ethical debate
all doctors agree that two feeder can't
be cured so while those in England argue
she should be able to die with dignity
the Italian system puts more emphasis on
the sanctity of life doctors here
disagree with the charge that this
transfer was undignified and even cruel
as a doctor to read a lot of time the
world foot I'll because for her speaking
foot I'll or using that word means that
you always have to get a success for
medicine it's not probably that's the
point I mean it's not always we're not
always able to to treat and to solve the
problems but we definitely we have to be
able to take care to feed his parents
say they want to get her Italian
citizenship to secure her future while
many are concerned with what precedent
this case sets one family are just
overjoyed their child has the chance to
fight on Helen Ann Smith Sky News in
Genoa Italy